let's talk about another big problem
authoritarianism and one of the big
problems is stupidity when you have an
authoritarian system that allows really
stupid people who lack merit to be on
top they do really really dumb things
and they use force to impose really dumb
things that break the system which
brings me to this tweet by juliet km
juliet is a harvard professor
remember that point and a cnn analyst
ceo of grip mobility she tweets the
convoy protest applauded by right-wing
media as a freedom protest is an
economic and security issue now the
ambassador bridge link can link
constitutes 20 of annual trade between
us and canada slash the tires empty gas
cans arrest the drivers and move the
trucks now i'd like to just um
start with some rudimentary math
slash the tires
empty the gas cans arrest the drivers
and move the trucks how do you propose
to move the trucks after you've slashed
their tires after the gas cans and
arrested the drivers and how do you and
how do you actually start moving and
actually shipping things from coast to
coast or across the borders if you don't
have actual trucks to do it in she says
it constitutes 28 of annual trade
because of the truckers
wow see this is this is why i'm you got
to be really careful about despotism and
authoritarianism because this is a
harvard professor yeah telling people
this my response to this was it's no
wonder they think two plus two equals
five right they can't do basic logical
steps it was like it was like joe
biden's infrastructure bill it's gonna
cost us zero and then all of a sudden it
was like how does trillions of dollars
cost us zero but that's their math they
they want it to sound that way even
though they know it's not that way when
he was saying us he was referring to
like himself and his political allies
it's not gonna cost us anything yeah you
guys will pay that bill yeah we're
taking it from your pocket so i saw the
word security up here it makes me
nervous talking about national security
before the show because it's become such
an integral part of our society this
word this concept national security
didn't exist before 2003. no one ever
talked about it they used 911 in this
war in iraq to justify be afraid be
afraid be afraid and we need to secure
you let us secure you and now they're
yelling out oh it's threatening my
security like come on but but let me
just stress real quick once again the
security threat is the trade but it's
the truckers who facilitate that trade
that she's threatening it's like it's
it's a security issue if we can't have
trade so go after those who facilitate
it yeah i mean
what is there ever a thank you is there
ever thank you to the people who brought
you your food and all of these
unbelievably important things that we
have to trade to have a sustainable
economy no well people are seeing it now
though aren't they i mean look every one
of our restaurants or our grocery stores
are on forced diets i mean we see the
supply chain issues we're seeing ships
moored off on the coast that you know
they can't actually come on we see like
the entire breakdown while pete budejig
you know goes on vacation and we can't
get everything you know locked down but
but you're right i mean the very people
who want to attack
those responsible for transporting all
of those or saying you're impacting our
ability to supply well let's slash your
tax oh well how's that going to help
exactly well like an autoimmune disease
how do you
disease treating the symptom without
recognizing the disease well and i want
to make a point here she's referring to
these workers standing up for themselves
as a security issue because that makes
it more difficult for us to have a
functioning economy so
if making it more difficult to have a
functioning economy is a security issue
then the most violent psychopaths we're
aware of are all in government because
currently our national debt is at 30
trillion dollars and as of january 31st
2022 that is 90 000 of debt for every
living person in the u.s i just want to
say this if there was a group of rioters
or radicals who caused so much damage to
the country that it totaled 30 trillion
dollars we would lock them up and throw
away the key public perception would be
completely against them and yet we
praise the state and when people stand
up for themselves and say they're not
going to take it anymore we demonize
them and call them the security threat
we don't the cult does it's true and so
that's why my attitude's lately just
been like yo i don't take these people
seriously especially like if you look at
my twitter as of tonight i've just been
having so much fun oh i've seen it it's
been fun to read yeah tim messaged me at
8 30 this morning like what if we've
been taken over by my space mind worms
i'm like he's in the right mode right
that's [ __ ] up so ian's always got
good crazy he's like tim rolled to 20. i
was watching no no it's because i was
watching some sci-fi camera what it was
where um i was watching uh uh peacemaker
i haven't seen it so uh well then i
can't spoil it is that cena john cena
yeah john cena um
man i guess this is a partial spoiler if
you've been watching the series
so you've been warned i'll give you a
few more seconds i'm gonna say it again
uh i was watching peacemaker i think
it's a great show
and a component of the show is aliens
taking over people's bodies so i
messaged ian and i was like what if the
aliens are invading the earth and that's
why they're telling everybody you got to
go out and get the injections i'm
thinking
well just to be fair the dod did
unclassify what was it last year or
something that that they did actually
have you know unidentified uh flying
objects it didn't it was during the
riots during the code lockdown i feel
like everyone's like had bigger issues
they were like yeah whatever you know
ufos yeah
they're here i'm ready to go out i think
it might be well if it's anything maybe
it's like a have you ever seen kymatics
where like they vibrate um a membrane
with sand on it and then they did the
depending on the frequency it makes
these crazy shapes if you look it up on
youtube it's getting sound waves and i
wonder if we're being bombarded by
vibration from extraterrestrial sources
that are causing us to act
we're being bombarded by
ignorance sound waves and that's mostly
coming from the left it's coming from
the tv it's coming from cable
mainstream yeah mainstream media but
hold on i i so ian i wouldn't call that
rolling a one
i would say that um i like the analogy
imagine you've got you know brian
stelter and rachel maddow and they're
both on two different tvs with their
resident frequencies of fake news
garbage and it's making regular people
lose their mind i have put on i took
like five of my own youtube videos and
turned them all on at the same time and
started listening and it was really
soothing i highly recommend it
you guys should all try it
no i'm good the more videos the better i
have a feeling to put on like a thousand
videos it sounds like music like ocean
waves and music or something
i wanted to go back to a point that
you're bringing up and we discussed it
earlier but talking about this national
deficit that we're looking at i mean the
30 trillion plus dollars and i wanted to
you know one of the things we were
discussing was that a lot of people are
incorrectly and tim you mentioned
something earlier about using the wrong
language and you know people are always
talking about oh we want a balanced
budget we want a balanced budget but i
don't think they understand what that
actually means i mean that would mean
rapid hyper taxation etc etc i think
what people are really trying to say
what we need to control over is one yes
we need physical conservativity but what
we need is we need to ensure that our
gdp to debt ratio
is basically what is balanced this is
modern monetary theory like you can
spend as much as you want as long as
you're going to create more profits
that's exactly right and one of the ways
that we are able to continue to thrive
is again to go back to the america first
agenda of looking at domestic production
looking at the ideas of controlling like
president trump did where we had oil
independency you know we weren't
approving other people's oil pipelines
like nordstrom 2 for russia who's
economically advancing themselves and
ingratiating themselves with germany who
they control all their oil and gas we
had our own independence of this i mean
you think about it in 2017 you know in
october we were only importing like 21
000 barrels from russia
this october this past one we imported
216 000 barrels from russia so if you
look at that we are literally with china
and russia china always say is the
greatest existential threat but when you
look at this we're literally funding and
economically advancing our adversarial
nations while increasing our spending
and not controlling our gdp to debt
ratio i think it's on purpose
of course it is yeah donald trump was
like let's not do this and joe biden was
like let's do it also i i just want to
make a point here with respect to mmt
i'm against that for a number of reasons
but one of the primary ones is we sort
of saw a de facto mmt with the
government printing trillions of dollars
over the past couple years and i don't
trust them to have any more influence
over the economy than they already have
the way the constitution is written is
congress is supposed to control the
money but instead they offloaded the the
responsibility to the federal reserve
when they kind of secretly created it
over christmas now if we gave the
control back to khan are you saying
you'd still be uncomfortable with
congress in control of it yeah well i'm
uncomfortable with mmt in general for a
number of reasons it's a really
complicated topic but one of the issues
with it is they argue we can print as
much money as we want and we won't have
inflation as long as the economy grows
at an equal pace to the amount of money
that we're going to see this is
difficult
one of the difficulties with that though
is then you have to depend upon the
government to generate the proper work
programs in order to get people fully
employed while they're producing all
this this is where i think is the
falsity i you know like president reagan
used to say if the scariest words ever
is that we're here from the we're from
the government we're here to help yeah i
mean look the reality is that americans
create america jobs you know the every
time that the government has tried to
come in and build our economy or stop
unemployment or things like this they
have failed massively and they've only
served to do things like bailing out of
solyndra you know remember remember
obama's solyndra the 1.1 billion dollar
scheme basically what it was look
the the government needs to get out and
stop over regulating american businesses
and allow us you know that was a great
thing about president trump's tax reform
i know as a business owner that we were
able to take that money and bring on
more people in the state of florida to
work for us and that enabled us to do
more with our money and that's exactly
what government is supposed to be doing
isn't enabling you not over regulating
you yeah absolutely and this is
interesting because you were sort of
mentioning earlier an increase in taxes
in order to balance the budget but what
a lot of people don't consider is the
fact that tax cuts can actually generate
more revenue and the trump tax cut was
an example of that the media repeatedly
said that we ended up with an increased
deficit because of those tax cuts but
that's not true we ended up with a five
percent surplus over what we were
expected to have but we spent 10 percent
more i liked it and that's that's why we
haven't dealt with that money by the way
which is brilliant he took some of our
extra and additional money and he plus
back up our oil reserves did you see
what biden did when he came back in he
actually sold some of our oil reserves
to china
wow amazing i mean i like i'd like to
explain this with a story
many of you may have heard many of you
may not
have told it before but
a friend of mine a friend of mine's dad
was explaining to me why raising taxes
had hurt tax revenue in cook county
chicago basically and what happened was
they increased the tax by like a
fraction of a percent they ended up
losing a ton of money because it's uh
the example given to me was he's like
i'm a contractor i'm gonna go to home
depot and i'm gonna do a big order it's
gonna be thousands of dollars the end of
the year i gotta calculate how much i
spend at home depot every time i went in
for supplies
when they raise the taxes that could be
twenty thousand dollars if i drive an
extra ten miles takes a little bit of
time out of my day i save 20 grand i'm
gonna do it absolutely that means the
revenue is going to a different county
correct so raising the taxes
they lost money yeah right and so
left-wing will often scoff at the idea
of the laffer curve and they'll even
call it pseudoeconomics the reality is
no competent economist on the left or
right denies the existence of the laffer
curve left-wing economists tend to say
that parabola peaks at a higher tax rate
so they'll say you can tax as much as 70
in certain sectors and you won't end up
negatively affecting revenue i think
that's ridiculous conservatives tend to
say it's more 20 but interestingly
enough
the amount of revenue the federal
government has pulled in has generally
hovered around 20 regardless of what the
tax rate was well you know i was
thinking about something um just with
everything that's been going on
especially with uh
the establishment left opposition to the
convoys and everything
we really are in an era where if one
side is for something the other side is
against it which is really dangerous it
leads us to serious conflict you know uh
the alec baldwin story is a good one
alec baldwin
should have checked the gun this should
be a a grand slam for the left who says
we need gun control and regulations but
now all of a sudden they're like alec
baldwin did nothing wrong by not
checking a gun and shooting them in the
chest it's crazy so i started thinking
about it i'm like maybe we should roll
their own yeah well maybe we should roll
with it and then when they say tax the
rich we say text the poor attack attacks
the poor well they're that's right
that's what inflation is i mean look
inflation is essentially you know
invisible taxation and we were talking
about this earlier
specifically i mean the middle class is
the one who takes it the most right
because that's what they're looking at
look there's one economical principle i
can guarantee and this is the the
principle why socialism doesn't work you
cannot multiply wealth by dividing it
that's a simple amen common thing all
right so but what they continue to do is
they think that i can't get certain tax
regulations or tax legislations you know
in because we don't have the majority
and the senate we're at a 50-50 and i
can't necessarily get it passed because
people won't take it on for the left so
what they do is they just continue to
print money and it's just taxation
through inflation which is exactly
looking for or defunding of our military
which we talked about earlier thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time